[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro pas
confiné des confiné en boitillant à
boiter l'autre puisque je suis en
plateau avec stéphane mon sens bonjour
patrick ancien doyen de l'université de
30 la faculté de l'université de
versailles saint quentin
vous êtes toujours professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et puis on a en a dans les écrans des
participants nous avons rost bonjour
rost
bonjour vous êtes le président de
banlieues actives et membre du conseil
économique social et environnemental
et puis vous êtes aussi un artiste aussi
rappeur vous est aussi écrivain et on a
beaucoup de sujets abordés avec vous
vincent couronne bonjour bonjour patrice
manger ou êtes enseignant de droit de
sciences politiques et vous êtes le
fondateur de collectifs qui s'appelle
les surligneurs et les surligneurs et
aux fausses qu'on appelle lui l'égal
checking c'est à dire que vous regardez
dans les déclarations notamment des
hommes politiques basques est possible d
pas possible ce qui est ce que les
réformes qu'on peut faire on peut pas
fait on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs souvent en
vous disant que souvent des hommes
politiques ou des femmes politiques
proposent des réformes qui existe déjà
drôle de droite donc c'est même pas la
peine de les proposer donc c'est tout à
fait intéressant et puis jean charles
lajoie dit bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes éditeur
toujours toujours nous voilà des
éditions la joie dit shi d'olive fidèle
au livre et vous avez bien raison alors
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de 6 est
évidemment de politique intérieure mais
je voudrais qu'on commence par quelque
chose qui nous est venue de belgique
mais qui nous concerne évidemment ce
sont des excuses qui ont été présentés
par le roi de roi des belges roi
philippe à l'égard du congo pour la
conduite de la belgique pendant la
colonisation excuses présentées au
peuple
congolais à l'occasion du 60e
anniversaire de son indépendance alors
intéressant parce que ça pose la
question est-ce qu'il faut s'excuser des
conduits de passer des conduites au
fonds qui ont été celles des pères ou
des grands pères et à quoi servent ses
excuses à ce jeu ça efface ou dont le
passé est ce que ça la moindre i je
voudrais peut-être commencer par vous
rust sur cette attitude du roi philippe
comme on vous l'a jugé écoutez moi je
veux saluer une démarche qui est une
démarche qui est ancré dans notre époque
et ses exigences pour plusieurs raisons
il faut savoir que à cette époque là il
ya eu pratiquement 12 millions de
personnes qui ont été tuées et à ce
moment là
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une période
l'histoire s'écrit en permanence et même
si on sait que chez nous on dit
l'histoire appartient à celui qui gagne
la guerre parce que c'est eux qu'il
écrive donc il certains ont écrit
l'histoire à leur manière sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plein de choses
qu'il ya énormément de choses qui
émergent et il y à un peuple qui en
souffrance depuis très longtemps qui est
sous domination depuis très longtemps et
il ya une nouvelle génération qui elle
dit stop stop parce qu'inconsciemment
inconsciemment beaucoup de gens agissent
au nom de cette domination au nom de
cette supériorité qu'on leur a mis dans
la tête depuis très longtemps à l'égard
de dinde d'un peuple et donc le fait de
reconnaître c'est comme c'est comme dans
un statut entre guillemets parce que
j'aime pas trop ce mot là parce que
quand on utilise les gens déjà du mans à
partir du moment où on parle de ses
sujets où on parle de la question les
questions d'exclusion
on dit qu'on est dans la victimisation
mais le statut de victime
il est important oui c'est pas on n'est
pas en train de dire aujourd'hui que les
blancs sont des sondés sont la
génération actuelle ce sont des
colonisateurs mais ya eu des choses qui
ont été faites par leur grand-père leur
arrière-grand-père et et donc il
une manière aujourd'hui de voir comment
on peut solder définitivement ces
parties sombres de notre histoire de
l'humanité
il faut la solde et c'est impératif
reconnaître le statut de victime à
quelqu'un c'est déjà une première étape
pour sa reconstruction
et on est dans ce processus là et c'est
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui
après il ya des gens qui pillent mélange
tout donc on mélange ça on mélange ça
avec la question du des bleus du
déboulonnement de certaines statues
j'espère d'ailleurs qu'on aura
l'occasion d'aborder sari polluant et
est donc voilà de mon point de vue en
tout cas moi je veux vraiment saluer son
courage surtout dans une époque où la
lâcheté politique est courante
je veux vraiment le saluer cette
démarche vous vous dites ça reconnaît on
il reconnaît une histoire qui a existé
vous foncez ça mais il reconnaît une
histoire qui a existé et il reconnaît
aussi les drames que ça a pu causer
derrière c'est quand même je le répète
c'est 12 millions de personnes qui ont
été tuées au nom de ça au nom de cette
domination
c'est pas rien quand même qui veut qui
veut interdire ces sujets peut-être
jean-charles d'accord donc non oui bien
sûr on peut rarement est d'accord mais
c'est tellement évident alors c'est très
bien ses excuses et deviennent bien bon
moment mais pourquoi pas oui
maintenant est-ce que j'ai jamais
entendu personne ni ce qui s'est passé
et nier cette captation et ce est ce ce
quasi génocide qui s'est passé il ya des
années donc on est tous d'accord là
dessus alors maintenant qu'on a dit ça
qu'à son avis ben on n'a rien dit et
maintenant elles jusqu où est-ce qu'il
faut remonter dans cette repentance
permanente dans ses excuses en
permanence voilà je ne sais pas et etc
sans limite
on va remonter à chaque fois tous les
dix ans et est ce qu'à un moment on va
dire ok on n'est pas ce que l'euro était
responsable de ce qu'ont fait ces
ancêtres non est-ce que je suis
responsable de ce qu'ont fait plaisance
est non voilà alors
maintenant ça va on peut y aurait
peut-être passer à autre chose
construire quelque chose et arrêter ces
espèces de mea culpa permanent qui
sortent de bonne conscience que les gens
et c'est le devenir assez bien on va se
mettre à genoux on va battre notre
coulpe
pourquoi non c'est juste c'est sans
aucun avenir
et c'est surtout sans aucune utilité à
part de rassurer comme cette occasion
invité
d'après ce que dit et rost vincent
corrodé pyross souvent on a la parole
après oui j'ai eu jean charles je suis
je suis à moitié d'accord avec vous en
fait je pense pas que si l'état s'excuse
c'est que on reconnaît notre propre
responsabilité dans ce qui s'est passé
là pense qu'il faut distinguer à mon
avis les excuses de l'état qu'il est à
lui responsable pour ce qui s'est passé
mais mais nous quand elle vous et moi on
n'est pas responsable ce qui s'est passé
ce qu'ont fait nos grands parents etc
fonctionnent vraiment je pense que c'est
extrêmement important que l'état puisse
s'excuser parce que l'état lui bien il
est là pour une durée illimitée il était
en 1950 qui a fait ça c'est toujours les
mêmes et ans en 2020 et donc il doit il
doit réparer tout simplement
mais nous effectivement on n'est pas
responsable de ce qu'ont fait nos adieux
de sinnoh on tomberait un peu dans le
travers de jean paul sartre qui avait
préfacé le les damnés de la terre de
frantz fanon avec une préface intitulé
le mcs massacrant les européens et
pourquoi est ce qu'il fallait massacré
européenne simplement parce que il avait
été complice de la colonisation
alors sans aller jusque là moi je pense
que là c'est des simples excuses de
l'état
chirac l'a fait en 95 à l'égard de de
juillet normal
macron l'a fait en 2018 à l'égard de la
devise inquiéter un communiste sortir en
algérie bon voilà mêmes même le congrès
américain l'avait fait aussi à l'égard
d' esclavage et la ségrégation il a fait
ça en 2009 donc ça me semble assez
important et comme vous disais je pense
que c'est important c'est pouvoir solder
notre histoire
et si je peux juste faire un rappel
rapide de dernis trônant qui donc dans
son discours 4 qu'une nation en 82
disait qu'une nation en fait simplement
c'est une nation lorsqu'elle accepte le
legs de son histoire et je pense que
pour elle et à s'excuser c'est aussi
accepter
toutes les facettes de son espoir sans
forcément dire que les personnes qui
vivent aujourd'hui sont responsables de
ce qui s'est passé
absolument rost et puis et puis stéphane
ans son frère hussein voulait en fait
c'est ça et je les précisé d'ailleurs
dans ma première intervention je le dis
clairement il s'agit pas de dire que la
nouvelle génération les est responsable
de quoi que ce soit il s'agit juste que
l'on reconnaisse à un moment qu' il ya
eu des massacres qui a eu un génocide
qui a été commis et que il faille revoir
la manière dont on gère parce que nous
on est on est même plus dans l'absolu je
vais vous dire moi quand j'entends déjà
entendu marion le pen faire sa sortie en
disant oui mais moi j'y suis pour rien
de ce que mes pas mes grands parents ou
mon peuple a pu faire personne ne lui
demande quoi que ce soit en personne
demandé à la nouvelle génération de dire
qu'elle est coupable de quoi que ce soit
et elle n'est coupable de rien du tout
toutefois et puis en plus nous on est
vraiment très loin on est on est plus
loin que ça on est loin dans le trou
c'est qu'on est on demande aujourd'hui
cette reconnaissance qui n'est qui est
loin d'être son histoire de repentance
ça c'est le mot qu'ils ont à la bouche
l'aller les gens de droite qui ne
veulent pas ils veulent pas avancer sur
sur l'histoire qui sont qu'à qualité qui
sont encore dans leurs dents dans l'or
dans leur stupidité du passé mais je
leur laisse ça mais concrètement la
nouvelle génération elle dit il ya eu
une manière de fonctionner qui
aujourd'hui perdu en fait c'est ça qui
se passe c'est que cette domination
cette façon de faire de penser que ces
états appartiennent toujours justement à
ces colonies à ces colons malgré tout ce
qui fait que même les présidents
africains parce que j'entends souvent
les gens qui disent oui mais attendez
vous président en même temps c'est eux
qui sont responsables ils sont
responsables de rien du tout parce que
ce sont des pantins nos présidents
africains sont des pantins d'un système
qui est mis en place
et lorsqu'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
elle et avec ce qui profite aux intérêts
occidentaux
ils sont
assassiné c'est ce qui se passe
concrètement moi j'ai rencontré plein de
gens qui travaillent auprès de pas mal
de présidence j'ai même eu des
discussions avec certains présidents
africains et je sais comment ça se passe
même lorsque les la france veut certes
un certain projet dans certains pays
et lorsque les politiques de ces pays ne
sont pas d'accord il y à des
manipulations qui sont faites
il y à des stratégies qui sont mises en
place pour déstabiliser certains pays et
en fait c'est ça qu'on dénonce
aujourd'hui parce que ça fait toujours
partie de cette partie de la
colonisation et l'arrivée justement des
du brésil l'arrivée de la chine
même si on peut voilà moi je ne sais pas
c'est pas une arrivée que je trouve
joyeuse je préférerais que ses intérêts
profite plutôt à la france mais ça
permet de remettre le 4 mai carte et on
a vu ce qui s'est passé en libye par
exemple on a vu ce qui s'est passé en
côte d'ivoire est aujourd'hui laurent
gbagbo souvenons nous qu'en même que
laurent gbagbo a été blanchi de ces
accusations
sauf que il ne peut toujours pas rentré
dans son pays
et on est un demande à la cpi comment se
fait-il que on déloge un président que
la france des loges un président de la
république on placer quelqu'un qui va te
servir leurs intérêts et aujourd'hui
l'autre qui est blanchi n'a même pas le
droit de rentrer dans son pays il y a et
quelque chose qui ne va pas et tout ça
nous notre génération contrairement à
nos aînés et allo parents nous on
comprend tout ça on a étudié tout ça on
essaye de comprendre toutes ces
stratégies et c'est pour ça qu'on parle
de ces histoires de reconnaissent dans
de la colonisation que les effets de la
colonisation on puisse les combattre ça
ne passera que par ça et c'est ça là où
la petitesse d'esprit de certains
restent uniquement sur l'aspect surface
mais ne voit pas tout ce qu'il ya autour
et les conséquences de la séquestration
justement de l'émancipation de l'afrique
à travers cette histoire c'était fait
bon sens et il les raisons restent au
fond vous évoquez ce que le système
qu'on appelle le système de la
françafrique on a vu la difficulté d'en
sortir je me souviens que quand votre
collègue jean pierre cot et ministre de
la coopération qu'il avait essayé d'en
sortie elle a été virée du jour au
lendemain de son ministère et c'est vrai
que c'est un système malgré les les
évolutions politiques intérieures
françaises qui perdure oui alors ça
c'est une chose c'est que ça donne de la
géopolitique etc et rust avait raison de
préciser que pour le le fonctionnement
entre guillemets de la françafrique
il faut être deux et que les élites
largement corrompu les élites africaines
très largement corrompu notamment par la
france mais pas seulement
reste à parler de la chine je fais un
travail de corruption et d'entrisme qui
est gigantesque font que les choses sont
quand même d'une très grande complexité
mais au regard de ski de ce qui vient
d'être dit moi j'avais simplement deux
observations la première c'est que et je
rejoins rust sur ce point il faut que
les historiens et ils le font d'ailleurs
depuis quelques années depuis quelques
décennies que l'existence rien met à
jour un récit historique qui a pendant
trop longtemps alors autour de la
question du récit national par exemple
qui a pendant trop longtemps n'ont pas
nié mais occulte et parfois nier
certains certains faits certains aspects
de la colonisation sous la troisième
république triomphante ont considéré
sous l'égide de lui l'idéologie du
progrès que la colonisation c'était
quelque chose de très bien et ya de
grands humanistes qui à la fin du 19e
siècle ont défendu le principe même de
la décolonisation
j'allais dire de toute bonne foi donc ça
c'est notamment un travail d'historien
il faut rétablir les faits les regarder
en face et si j'ose dire se les
approprier mais seconde observation le
la logique des excuses je leur ai prouve
la réprouve très fortement
d'ailleurs le roi des belges n'a pas
présenté d'excusés il a présenté des
regrets
et il ya débat a aujourd'hui au
parlement belge
il ya débat au congo ex congo république
du congo dans la vie politique
congolaise
puisqu'il ya des leaders politiques qui
disent mais on se fiche de nous on veut
plus que des regrets on veut des excuses
et puis d'autres disent on veut plus que
des excuses on veut une contrition avec
un mécanisme de réparation
donc il mettre le doigt dans cette
logique de contrition c est là je
rejoins jean charles
c'est sans limite c'est sans fin et il
ya aujourd'hui une commission
parlementaire à bruxelles parlement
belge qui s'est réuni et qui travaille
et qui doit statuer sur le fait de
savoir si le royaume de belgique va à
l'issue de cette enquête présentée ou
pas des excuses c'est à dire passer des
regrets est aux excuses et voeux des
excuses et ainsi de suite
donc ça ça je le réprouvent en revanche
ce que j'approuve
c'est une logique de reconnaissance
jacques chirac en 1981 il avait raison à
100 couronnes
il avait raison à la seule réserve près
qu'il me semble que jacques chirac au
discours du vel d'hiv n'a pas présenté
les excuses de la france mais a reconnu
connu une stabilité de l'état
ce que mitterrand a considéré et
inavouables enfin impossible
chirac l'a reconnu et cette logique de
reconnaissance
oui elle est là elle nous mais
objectivement face à notre histoire face
aux heures chaudes de notre histoire que
nous devons tous sans distinction nous
approprier pour en tirer des
conséquences sur le temps présent et sur
le ton futur
oui on peut pas dire la colonisation
c'est pas la france comme maintenant
mais qu'on me dise navy pendant
longtemps vie si ce n'est pas la france
diane entendre de gaulle et mitterrand
bien sûr mais pas la france
rost peut-être vous disiez alors il faut
distinguer au fond peut-être une réponse
à ce que dit stéphane mention d'abord
est ce que oui voilà les fonds les
excuses ont nommé le pied dans un
engrenage difficile non mais dans
l'absolu les excuses nous on s'en fout
ce qui est important c'est justement la
reconnaissance de l'histoire
et puis surtout justement avec ce que ça
engendre
ça veut dire que c'est en fait ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que j'ai eu et
j'ai des gens qui m'ont interpellé dans
la rue parfois il n'ya pas très
longtemps d'ailleurs il y avait trois
couples et avec une virulence sur les
choses en me disant oui c'est
inadmissible ce qui se passe avec les
manifestations avec si avec ça avec les
gens qui déboulonne des statuts et un
moment je lui dis mais et en plus en
parlant après des violences qui auraient
eu lors des manifestations d'adama
traoré enfin - un mélange de tout et je
lui ai expliqué d'ailleurs que qu'on se
faisait que je lui ai expliqué comment
se passer la manifestation qui était
pacifique et qu'à la fin on était
menacée et que ont été gazés par les
policiers souvent cette offensive selon
mais attendez vous allez comprendre
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que sinon
et donc il est vraiment je dis on s'est
fait gazer
elle me dit mais c'est inadmissible que
vous utilisiez le mot gaz et parce que
je sais pas quoi et est donc j'ai
compris que c'était quelque chose qui
lui rappelait à elle l'histoire son
histoire à elle je lui ai posé une
question justement à ce moment là sur
les questions d état de l'aider des
statuts je le dis est ce que vous
aujourd'hui s'il y avait une statue de
pétain à vichy
est-ce que vous bat trier pour qu'elle
soit déboulonner elle m'a dit mais bien
évidemment qu'il faudrait lundi qu'il
sait même pas pensable
et d'ailleurs je crois que ça a été le
cas historiquement je crois qu'il y
avait une statue de de petacchi a été
déboulonnée et je m'expliquais qu'il y
avait eu des routes des rues ont été
rebaptisés un nom de l'histoire
justement qui que qui a été subie sur
quoi est dit oui mais c'est pas pareil à
pourquoi ça serait valable pour certains
et pas pour d'autres je veux dire c'est
pour ça que je trouvais que c'était
intéressant que ce qu'il dit c'est que
les historiens doivent se poser les
historiens de tout horizon doivent se
poser pour écrire l'histoire réellement
et que on arrête de continuer à
coloniser l'esprit des gens et ce qui
fait d'ailleurs que quand les gens sont
pas instruits
souvent ils racontent des conneries et
ils vont vers des dérives qui n'ont rien
à voir dans le faux alors que les choses
seraient beaucoup plus simple que ça que
de se dire à un moment oui il ya eu
cette histoire on assume on se pose à
table on voit comment on peut essayer
d'avancer
et comme on peut régler les choses pour
que les nouvelles générations ne n'est
plus ce sentiment justement d'avoir leur
avenir qui est séquestré et à cause des
questions de géopolitique et tout ça qui
sont encore sous le joug justement de
celui qui les a colonisé parce que la
décolonisation pour nous elle est juste
et aux ricains je peux vous le dire et
c'est le sentiment de tous les africains
qui ont un minimum de d'études et vous
le disent tous la colonisation la
décolonisation est juste théorique
vincent et jean charles à on va pas
aborder le faux de de savoir s'il faut
déboulonner ou pas des statuts mais
l'idée quand même qu'on peut regarder
l'histoire l'art regarder est ce que ça
vous choque ou pas jean charles je pense
qu'un peu mais les vignes non mais moi
ça me choque pas j'ai fait des études
d'histoire j'avais en l'histoire et
l'histoire si ce cas plus importants
mais l'histoire edouard part justement
être déteste ce mot de l'employé par
rost et consorts c'est cette réécriture
ce terme de réécriture ça m'évoque tout
ce qui peut y avoir de pire dans le dans
des régimes qui sont de moins en moins
démocratique donc on réécrit et puis
suivant le groupe de pression on réécrit
dans un sens
pour calmer les foules alors que c'est
très bien mais c'est extrêmement
dangereux
y'a pas de réécriture des historiens
font très bien leur boulot
comme le dit très justement stéphane
mans sont les historiens sapé comme
quelques décennies qu'ils s'y mettent et
il faudrait simplement que ross et ses
amis lisent ces historiens plutôt que de
rester calée sur des trucs vieillissant
etc
les choses avancent et l avance dans le
bon sens l'histoire se fait l'histoire
est tout à fait intéressante est tout à
fait bien enseigné dans nos universités
et et dans les livres qu'on peut acheter
et que beaucoup de gens devraient
acheter avant de s'exprimer
et voilà il n'y a pas de besoin de
réécrire ce que je déteste et je ne
supporte pas ce thème de l'écriture
on sait très bien qu'on a exactement la
réalité l'histoire et les amalgames
tout d'un coup faire glisser alors que
le débat on est en train de parler du
roi des belges et on arrive sur pétain à
vichy mais c'était un gloubi boulga
intellectuelle qui peut peut-être faire
illusion auprès de gens qui ne
réfléchissent pas beaucoup mais ça n'a
aucun sens aucun sens d'ailleurs c'est
s'est noyé le poisson et dont j'avais
l'esprit beaucoup trop étriqué pas
comprendre les risques et deux autres et
puis après on va passer à un autre sujet
oui si je veux aussi faire un exercice
de synthèse aux cetc
je dirais que comment dire si je reviens
juste sur un point la question de la
reconnaissance ou des excuses par l'état
je pense que c'est nécessaire mais que
c'est pas forcément mettre le doigt dans
un engrenage
parce que c'est dans le politique de
fixer aussi les limites de 2 jusqu'où
est ce que il faut il faut aller et dans
chaque cas particulier alors vis-à-vis
par exemple d'haïti à la question de la
dette vis-à-vis l'esclavagé des tas de
choses que ça maintenant c'est vrai que
l'argument l'engrenage ça me rappelle un
petit peu faut avoir confiance aussi
l'emploi politique et le débat le débat
au site public pour fixer des limites
parce que tout ça me rappelle un peu le
débat sur la loi sur le mariage pour
tous soit l'époque on disait que marié
des personnes de même sexe ensemble
c'était de mettre le doigt aussi dans un
engrenage et que
bonjour omar et les animaux ou des gens
évidemment c'était absolument absolument
faux et fort leur vie mais est donc la
question des limites ça vient aussi à la
commande et ça mais là la question des
statuts c'est à dire que et de
l'histoire en général parce que les
statuts simplement la face visible en
fait de notre soir considération
l'histoire acceptation d'histoire et c
est la question des statuts en fait
c'est une question de est-ce qu'on va
commémorer ou célébrer une personne
où est ce qu'on va plutôt la garder en
mémoire une statue des confédérés par
exemple aux états unis est-ce qu'il faut
la mettre devant une mairie où est-ce
qu'elle a sa place dans un musée
moi je pense qu'elle a plutôt sa place
dans un musée la salle colbert à
l'assemblée nationale est-ce qu'il faut
la rebaptiser dont il faut voir aussi qu
est-ce qu on se souvient des personnes
colbert on s'en souvient non pas par
rapport au peu de noir vient par rapport
à quoi bon colbertisme et alors qu'il ya
eu des effets aussi sur la colonisation
etc
mais dans ces cas là dessus et si on
rentre dans cette logique là versailles
ont fermé pions ou non
jeudi c'est aussi le créateur de l'état
colbert de l'état français oui en tout
cas il a été et ça pose le problème
d'ailleurs ce que s'ils ont déboulonné
la statue de colbert est ce que ça
enlève pour autant le code noir n'ont en
revanche et après tout ce débat est
respectivement stéphane e historiquement
aux havrais historiquement oui c'était
un progrès que c'était l'occasion
s'était fixé un statut pour les noirs
qui notamment fixé pour les esclaves
noirs africains qui fixait un statut
alors évidemment c'est horrible à
regarder avec avec cinq à vingt quatre
siècles de recul mais à l'époque c'était
le propriétaire de l'esclave l'esclave
était considérée globalement comme un
meuble comme un bien
le propriétaire faisait de son esclave
ce qu'il voulait avec ce code avec ses
textes il y avait quelques limites à
regarder ça encore une fois avec quatre
siècles de recul
évidemment ça s'est passé c'est
complètement fou mais à l'époque c'était
mais c'était déjà ça de pris
c'est vrai qu'il vaut d'être aussi se
garder de de juzet époque quand arrière
avec nos yeux d'aujourd'hui a pas de
pardon oui je pense qu'il faut il faut
il faut reconnaître réparé mais pas
faire d anachronisme cellule alors on va
passer le deuxième sujet c'est la
condamnation d'un ancien premier
ministre on avait déjà eu la
condamnation d'un ancien président de la
république avec jacques chirac
condamnation d'un ancien premier
ministre
c'est ça en dit beaucoup sur une époque
ces événements sont de la vie politique
ça dit beaucoup je crois de la vie
politique telle qu'elle est encore
aujourd'hui c'est à dire avec beaucoup
de mauvaise foi beaucoup de
manipulations et et tout et n'importe
quoi sur ce sur ce sujet on mélange tout
enfin le ceux qui se permettent les
quelques quelques élus quelques grands
élus ex soutien ou soutiens actuels
enfin j'en sais rien si view est
toujours utile de le soutenir ou pal de
françois fillon se sont fendus de
déclaration ou de commentaires qui sont
au mieux grotesque au pire complètement
manipulateur et qui prennent les gens
pour des imbéciles
vous pensez à ceux qui disent la fête
c'est une affaire montée de toutes
pièces
il fallait un coupable désigné c'est à
dire que là aussi deux brèves
observations
la première c'est que on parle de quoi
de qui on parle du parquet et le parquet
les magistrats du parquet ne sont pas
des juges
j'ai lu dans la grande presse jeudi la
grande presse la presse digne de ce nom
la presse papiers s'il vous plaît il ya
deux jours la juge houlette eliane blatt
qui aimeraient le procureur du parquet
national financiers c'est pas un juge
les lianes houlette est à l'epo retraite
aujourd'hui magistrate mais elle n'est
pas juge
un membre du parquet ne juge pas mais
lance des poursuites et la situation
pour l'instant c'est qu'en france le
parquet n'est pas indépendant il est
soumis aux directives de politique
pénale général du gouvernement alors
c'est bien c'est pas bien c'est un autre
débat
je note au passage que les les élus la
république les républicains qui se sont
exprimés avaient à l'époque voté contre
le principe de l'indépendance du parquet
national financiers canadian vient ce
qui est soumis à la hiérarchie du
parquet général de la cour d'appel de
paris
et puis la seconde la seconde
observation insiste sur le fait qu'il ya
ici une très forte contradiction
pourquoi parce que les les directives
les influences mais les influences
juridiquement fondé de la procureur
général de paris à l'encontre de la
procureure financière cette influence a
joué essentiellement on va voir ce que
dit madame chan renault aujourd'hui dans
la commission parlementaire mais de ce
que j'en ai lu ont essentiellement joué
sur les modalités de poursuite les
modalités denquête une initialement une
enquête préliminaire avait été
diligentée qu'est ce que c'est
simplement qu'une enquête préliminaire
sur une enquête qui est à la totale mans
maîtrisé par le parquet par le procureur
et le procureur demande à la police de
bien vouloir livrer mettre au jour
certains premiers éléments des éléments
fondamentaux pour savoir ce qu'on fait
si on continue ou si on arrête le seul
problème c'est que les avocats la
défense n'a pas accès à cette enquête
préliminaire et donc le jeu des avocats
de françois fillon a consisté très
rapidement a demandé au plus vite la
transformation de cette enquête
préliminaire en une information
judiciaire l'information judiciaire
au contraire mais c'est un une modalité
enquête qui n'est plus conduites par le
parquet mais par un juge d'instruction
juge indépendant et auquel dossier
auquel la défense ce qui a été fait et
on sait que les instructions de bananes
chant renault procureur général de paris
allait en ce sens pour hâter madame
houlette de bien vouloir demander
l'ouverture
une information judiciaire oui le la
chose la plus invraisemblable ça serait
que ça dix ans d'un candidat à la
présidence de la république le parquet
général s'en lave les mains
et bien sûr évidemment alors c'est bien
enfin c'était enfin les sondages le
donnaient favori on était durant
quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle est évidemment un dossier
exceptionnel qui a sans aucun doute fait
l'objet d'un traitement exceptionnel sur
à l'époque mes demandes auraient pu et
il en être autrement
il n'en reste pas moins que le plus
lourd handicap le plus lourd boulet pour
françois fillon s'est lui-même sur ce
sujet il veut intervenir mais c'est
extraordinaire parce que au final aux
excès j'entends les gens qui disent oui
mais c'est cette affaire qui a plombé un
françois fillon c'est pour ça qu'il n'a
pas été élu non ce sont les électeurs
qui n'ont pas voté pour lui parce qu'il
a été quand même au bout des élections
ça c'est une première chose l'autre
chose moi en ce moment je ris je ris et
jury parce que je vois tout l'entourage
de françois fillon monte au créneau pour
dire que la justice est à manipuler que
la justice n'était pas égal que la
justice mais c'est nous qu'on pour
dénoncer ça sur la clé sur lui ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers populaires
parfois on nous disait mais attendez
vous mettez en cause la france et son
fonctionnement
vous êtes des horribles d d d d horrible
personne qui détestait la france et son
système alors que voilà aujourd'hui
c'est eux mêmes qui sont en train de
dire exactement la même chose sur cette
cette justice qui n'est pas toujours
équitable équipe et qui fonctionne à
plusieurs vitesses bon cela dit le même
cas mais je n'ai même pas m'étaler sluc
sur la faire moi je me souviens juste
je suis ravi que la justice est quand
même été au bout et que même si la
condamnation mois pour moi me paraît
très légère aux vues au vu de ce qui
s'est passé et le fait que ça soit quand
même faire
meetic avec lui oui et vous quand vous
êtes à cela à ces postes là vous devriez
être exemplaire et juste pour terminer
il ya une citation de 2 je me souviens
d'une citation de françois fillon qui
dit il y a il y as justice sociale entre
il ya injustice pardon il ya injustice
sociale entre ceux qui travaillent dur
peu et ceux qui ne travaillent pas et
reçoivent de l'argent public
merci monsieur fillon on pourrait
ajouter aussi qu'ils disaient il ne faut
qu'une panne est prononcée il faut
qu'elle soit appliquée et oui il imagine
quand le général de gaulle mis en examen
qui est quand même la plus belle bourde
il est qu'il ait fait peut-être
jean-charles et puis vincent sur ce
sujet écoutez vous et moi surtout que la
justice s'est remarquablement bien son
travail
je suis étonné que rost du même avis que
les amis de fillon pour critiquer la
justice comme d'habitude la justice
c'est le job le fait très bien on a deux
spécialistes ici qui peuvent nous nous
expliquer par le menu comment ça ce
moment ça fonctionne et l'explication
ses fans manceau était tout à fait
intéressant et voilà il n'y a pas grand
chose à dire après quand j'entends
routard bien évidemment c'est tellement
facile la peine légère on peut on peut
tout dire sauf que c'est une peine
légère de condamner quelqu'un deux ans
de prison parce que quand quelqu'un est
condamné à deux ans de prison et c'est
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien si vous
trouvez ça horrible rost mais
conséquente et que vous avez pas d'eux
en prison que c'est rien donc vous avez
un peu le juge a suffi à sauver sur la
dureté des peines se faisait fort c'est
assez curieux mais bon je ne vois pas en
quoi ce fn et légère elle est peut-être
juste mais en tout cas elle n'est pas
légère et condamner quelqu'un cinq ans
de prison dont deux ans ferme ce n'est
pas une peine légère et je note cette
parole que j'avais dit ça parce que
quand on verra où vous indigner tous les
jours pour beaucoup de choses on verra à
vous indigner quand quelques quelques
personnes seront condamnés à deux ans de
prison et que vous pur leur et à
l'injustice à l'horreur à la retourner
son pire époque de l'histoire
chacun voit midi à sa porte dans l'air
bien
patrick balkany et la justice ne soit
pas assez ferme à l'égard des
manifestants donc selon qu'on soit
conservée ou pas on va des avis
différents va sans couronne
oui maintenant ce que le problème en
fait dans toute cette histoire c'est la
question d'indépendance du parquet
tendre et on n'a pas marqué par par un
jour les suspicions à l'origine une
ironie faut la voir françois fillon et
son équipe hurler contre ces fameuses
ses supposés pression qui alors en
réalité aller dans le sens de l'intérêt
de françois fillon est il était
probablement fait en plus à sa demande
donc ça ça je veux dire c'est d'un
question les dépendances et il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant qui va se
passer dans quelques mois qu'ils
pourraient changer la donne vous êtes
peut-être pas entendu parler parler de
ça vaut stéphane ses fans j'imagine que
je vais chanter oui bien évidemment mais
dans quelques mois va se mettre en place
à paris un procureur européen
un programme européen qui sera
directement mis en place par l'union
européenne il en aura un dans chaque
état membre ni européenne et chaque fuir
européen sera là pour poursuivre tout
est atteinte aux intérêts financiers de
l'union
là la fraude à la tva par exemple etc
la particularité de ce procureur
européen c'est qui va travailler au avec
à côté des procureurs français et lui il
aura une indépendance totale
mais à bien y voir politique et ça à mon
sens ça va se faire safer vous donner
c'est à dire que des jeunes ça va faire
des jaloux et puis ça va montrer aussi
que un parc est totalement indépendant
en france parce que c'est le cas dans
quasiment tous les autres pays européens
il est indépendant et bien ça peut
fonctionner et à mon avis ça ça va faire
des émules
c'est vrai que alors en 2001 popov seul
sur ce débat sur la dépendance ou pas du
parquet et secteur de dire que nous on a
une vieille tradition centralisatrice
qui fait que ceux qui sont contre
l'indépendance du parquet pense que si
elles n'existaient les directives du
ministère de la justice devrait être
appliquée différemment selon les
territoires et selon les endroits sur le
des procureurs au fond il puisqu'il
serait libre c'est un peu l'argument
contre l'indépendance et c'est celui-là
en bo1 c'est ce à quoi sert cet
archétype politique pénale l'article
archétypes c'est là c'est le sait les
systèmes du parc américain qui est des
états unis a coûté qui sont ou ont n'a
de véritable politique pénale locale
milner vous allez dans une ville dans un
comté vous avez des politiques pénales
totalement différente on vous poursuivra
pour une infraction dans un comté on
vous poursuivra pas dans le nord si on a
finit l'action on passe aux municipales
parce que c'est intéressant peut-être
stéphane on peut faire peut-être un
petit bout sur ce qui s'est passé dans
les yvelines sur territoire dans les
municipales il ya il ya deux faits
intéressants c'est la verrière et
sainement tellement de la ville montrent
la ville perdue par le rassemblement
national terrain des bastions de enfin
un baise formation je serai à gagner
paris parce que cyril nantes avec
l'avait quand même avec anne remporté en
2014 les élections la faveur d'une
triangulaire il est d'une désunion
totale de 2 de son opposition de gauche
et puis la verrière évidemment la
verrière là pour le coup c'était un
piège de ti fief communiste qui l'a
aussi avec des divisions très forte au
sein de la majorité
l'ancienne majorité municipale qui a
donc favorisé le candidat de
l'opposition de droite
voilà c'est tout à fait notable vous
avez raison mais le reste pour le reste
pour le ce qui s'est passé dans les
yvelines
au fond c'est une fondamentalement une
assez grande stabilité avec une comment
dirais-je la plupart des communes qui
reviennent aux républicains au parti l
air c'est sans doute de ce point de vue
à l'image de ce qui s'est passé sur plan
national il ya un chiffre que je lisais
ce matin c'est que et c'est tout à fait
c'est beaucoup plus fort que au cours
des dernières élections municipales
83% des élus sortants ont été reconduits
83% c'est normal c'est énorme énorme et
l'os est intéressant parce que
tout le monde a titré les journaux de
temps soit la poussée verte
alors elle existe dans les grandes
villes est ce qu'elle est vraiment réel
enfin c'est une des questions que posent
ces élections municipales qui veut
intervenir là dessus vincent oui même si
c'est une poussée verte en fait de
façade
en réalité bon si c'est un paravent
parce que la poussée verte elle est
essentiellement dans des grandes villes
dans les très grandes villes en réalité
c'est dans des villes symboliques comme
bordeaux lyon et même marseille et le
dire même si le tout n'est pas joué
encore à ce jour n'est bon en réalité
ces scellés les dips et ses dix huit
grandes villes que les verts entend
porter c'est à peu près tout en fait
en revanche la salle il sera lié à de la
gauche des verts allemands alors quand
ça ça effectivement et justement il faut
pas non plus trop relativiser ce succès
des tomber dans le travers inverse
parce qu'on méritait cette cette prise d
des grandes villes par les verts elles
montrent l'efficacité de l'union de la
gauche et l'union très souvent de la
gauche avec le ps derrière les écolos et
c'est pas pour rien que dès le soir même
des résultats des municipales olivier
faure le secrétaire général du psd parti
socialiste a déclaré que pour 2022 et la
présidentielle ils étaient prêts à
soutenir un candidat ps qui salit qui
salirait derrière le candidat écolo
alors là on a probablement ici la
préfiguration d'une potentielle l'union
de la gorge alors est-ce que ça
comprendrait les films passent à peu
probable mais en tout cas c'est un
probablement pour emmanuel macron qui
pensait jusqu au lac son danger était
sur sa droite il est peut-être en
réalité sur sa gauche alors c'est moi
c'est mon explication de ce vote mais je
vais vous la soumettre et puis vous
allez me dire moi c'est l'impression que
quand on les sondages nous disent le
match 2002 2022 ça sera le match retour
de 2017 c'est à dire marine le pen
contre emmanuel macron et donc les gens
disent oui ça sera ça mais quand on leur
demande ce qu'ils souhaitent ils disent
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas ce match retour
et à chaque fois que les français n'ont
pas souhaité un match retour dans les
présidentielles il n'a pas eu lieu
alors s
justement ils sont pas en train de
chercher une solution alternative à ce
ce match retour corp annonce comme fed
avancent pour dire rapidement un mot par
rapport à ce que ce que veulent les
français ou ce qu'ils ne veulent pas ça
me rappelle souvent sur les questions
européennes les français s'estiment
passer leur forme et sur les questions
européennes
ils veulent être mus sur les questions
européennes et quand l'armée puisse
d'europe à la télé il regarde pas on dit
les français disent ils veulent plus
d'informations positives aux infos au jt
et herat et les en informer leurs
programmes et quant à l'ambiance d'un
faut positiver regarde pas donc j'ai
l'impression que sur ce match ce match
retour en 2022 ils en veulent pas mais
qu'en réalité ils ont ils ont quand même
une chine tendance à aller à l'heure
alors elle aurait instauré
quoi qu'il en soit il voulait pas du
match chirac-jospin spa était
chirac-jospin ça a été le pen il voulait
pas du match retour
hollande sarkozy ni hollande ni sarkozy
non plus se présenter quand même quand
il ya des différences entre le souhait
des français et le l'opinion qu'ils ont
sur ce qu'il va se passer c'est
généralement le souhait qui gagne elle
est là dessus après je vous perdrez
street
aujourd'hui il faut il faut il faut
quand même faire attention à une chose
c'est que on est dans une période où les
médias jouent un rôle important dans
tout ça le premier pouvoir pour moi
aujourd'hui il réside dans les médias et
c'est eux qui plus ou moins impose
jusqu'à présent on n'a personne qui
émergent on ne fait on ne veut pas moi
j'ai cette impression là qu'on ne veut
pas lier d'autres personnes qui émerge
le peuple petit à petit fera le boulot
il nous reste deux ans bon en politique
ça peut aller très vite et dans le même
temps qu'ils en fassent aujourd'hui
concrètement qu'ils ont face à la
carrure en tout cas qui a mis en avant
comme ayant la cariou pour incarner
justement la présidence
à par match donc moi je pense que oui
pour l'instant en tout cas on se dirige
à nouveau vers ce duel entre macro et
marine le pen sauf que ce dont se
rendent pas compte beaucoup de gens
essaient médial d'ailleurs qui jouent à
ce jeu dangereux c'est que aux
prochaines élections je peux vous dire
une chose que la grande majorité
attention à ce que je vais dire la
grande majorité des gens que je connais
aujourd'hui si en 2022
on se retrouve avec macron et marine le
pen au deuxième tour
la grande majorité n'iront pas voter
je vous le dis comme tel et pourtant ce
sont des gens que je connais qui sont
des fervents combattants des deux du
droit de vote et et de l'exercice et je
peux vous dire que c'est ce qui va se
passer parce qu'ils sont tellement
dégoûtés par ce quinquennat que ils ne
feront pas la démarche quitte à prendre
le risque que marine le pen le pen passe
eh ben tu ce que les français puisque
ton on veut ça et bien allons-y et on
verra on verra ce qui va se passer mais
je proxim s'il y avait en effet ce match
là vous avez raison il y aurait une
forte abstention
jean charles lajoie nationale et de
chalandise des municipales plusieurs
choses on est à deux ans de cette
élection avant l'élection de deux ans
avant l'élection de mâcon qui aurait mis
un demi je tombe sur la river et
l'éclosion au longtemps avant et après
les faits dont on a quand même tout
notre temps pour pouvoir apparaître gens
payés dès l'instant pas aller enfin
l'émergence d'une touffe de cheveux
c'est je le reconnais deuxième chose il
faut faire attention dans toutes ses
analyses sur la poussée verte peut bien
évidemment réelle mais elle est aussi à
mon avis symptomatique d'une énorme
différence entre la france des villes et
puis le reste de la france
parce que sinon on aurait eu cette
poussée verte a tellement partout et on
a c'est de pousser le vert uniquement
dans les centres urbains alors sans
donner dans la caricature ya un côté un
peu bobo sympathique une écologie
agréable on est là on sait que va être
honnêtement ça va pas apporter beaucoup
au cnous et quand on se veut il ya une
telle multiplicité d'abord des
caractères des opinions et des courants
chez les verts on est tout à fait
tranquille avant que ce soit un grand
chambardement
donc je ne sais pas quels sont les liens
entre la maire de strasbourg le maire de
lyon etc et ça se trouve il pense pas du
tout la même chose de quoi que ce soit à
part peut-être sur le nucléaire pour ça
donc on a on a une multiplicité vraiment
démentiel et puis moi ce qui me paraît
vraiment c'est que en dehors de ces
villes
le beau-père il n'existe quasiment pas
donc ça c'est effectivement à prendre
parce que le concrètement ça fait
combien de gens qui votent vert pour
combien de gens qui ne votent pas bien
qu'ils ne s'intéressent pas et c'est
peut-être ce accueillir un peu dommage
mais que beaucoup de gens pour eux le
vert ne veut strictement rien dire c'est
même pas une alerte et c'est donc il ya
vraiment faisons attention cette
différence fondamentale entre une france
des villes et le reste de la france
sans compter la force de l'abstention
qu'on voyait que martine aubry est
arrivée à lille avec quinze mille voix
c'est quand même c'est c'est qu'en mai
et 222 223 points d'avance our heads et
223 d'avoir s'était pas de mensonge
on peut on peut analyser ces municipales
de dire ce maçon mais et il y en a un
qui doit les analyses et c'est le
président de la république est ce que
justement est-ce qu'il doit courir
derrière cette vague
r tu es ce que c'est pas comme disait
jean charles parce que c'est une
nébuleuse les verts yade du protest la
protestation il ya loti croissance il ya
des libéraux y
il a faim il ya beaucoup de choses qui
composent la mouvance verte
à votre avis qu'est ce qui est si vous
étiez emmanuel macron au nom non droit
je fus s'est jeté beaucoup je suis
extrêmement sollicité par beaucoup de
proches pour me présenter c'est une
chaîne élection présidentielle mais je
réponds même vous a proposé d'être
ministre ah oui oui je donne un
téléphone dans quoi non mais c'est vous
voyez enfin oui ce que vous dites la
course à une espèce de course à
l'échalote hier que moi ça me rappelle
ce qui se passe depuis ce qui s'est
passé depuis les années 1980 83,85 où on
parlait de cela à propos des idées du
front national
on disait voilà chacun va y met lui met
du sien pour essayer de s'approprier les
grandes thématiques du front national
l'immigration l'insécurité tout ça étant
lié etc
selon les dires du front national et on
a fait monter le front national
je crois que pour les verts il se passe
à peu près la même chose hier vous
n'avez plus personne aujourd'hui sur
l'échiquier politique et on l'a vu à ces
élections le pearl qui oseraient se dire
anti écologique entier anti transition
énergétique que sais-je encore même si
il faut bien examiner de près le
discours certains écologistes et pas de
tous parce que c'est vrai que c'est
aussi père il ya autant de courants qui
a d'écologistes les discours pseudo
scientifiques ou alarmistes sur sur la
5g sur l'énergie nucléaire que sais-je
encore bon mais le fait est que moi je
vote question si j'étais aujourd'hui à
l'élysée heureusement que je ne suis pas
ce que philippe ou par là on change de
région meda pour conclure sur la flore
si si si c'est le cas sur les
municipales moi je pense que il ya le
premier le premier phénomène face est
d'une absolue banalité que de le dire
mais c'est que 60% d'abstention aux
municipales ça n'a jamais existé
bon donc alors on peut trouver mille
raisons rationnelles
sont pas les santé mais enfin c'est pas
les seuls et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de fin d' absolument inédit et d'
extrêmement inquiétant la seconde
observation c'est ce que disait jean
charles c'est que et est ce que disait
tous nos interlocuteurs c'est que cette
cette poussée verte non c'est vraiment
un gros arbre prévisible qui tâchent la
forêt cette cette ville de plus de
100000 habitants sur 42 7 centres
urbains parce que les verts sont souvent
assez mal placé politiquement pour
remporter les intercommunalités
notamment les métropoles les communautés
d'agglomération etc
les vrais s'il fallait identifier des
gagnants à ceux de ce scrutin municipal
de mon point de vue ce sont les
républicains qui grosso modo conserve la
plupart alors oui sauf de mauvais
symbole dans sa vie et 83%
nous prîmes quand même aussi au sortant
et là il ya eu tous les sens tu es avec
sur la crise sanitaire
bien sûr donc bandes enregistrées non
c'est moi je voulais juste dire en même
temps que j'en sais rien sur
l'abstention dont tout le monde se se
gargarise etc
vous n'arrêtez pas que vous êtes bien
raison de répéter avant les élections
que 80 % des mères était réélu
là vous nous dites et vous avez tout à
fait raison que 83 % des mères sont
réélus comment vous imaginez que les
jambes se passionne réellement pour des
matchs qu'ils paraissent de la plupart
des gens aujourd hui d'avant je
comprends très bien que les gens ne se
déplacent pas c'est pas du tout dire
eric rohmer 8 fois sur 10 va être élu
c'est à la peine d'interroger la partie
de pêche où il devrait se lever le matin
et et doit s'y de risquer pour les gens
ils ont terrorisé d'attraper un virus
dont quoi ça je souhaite à mon président
d'organiser le premier tour au mois de
mars
oui mais est-ce que là je sais c'est de
là que tout découle parce que c'est vrai
que un parterre de salle la machine
était lancée on ne pouvait pas faire le
deuxième tour beaucoup plus longtemps
parce que ça bloquer le fonctionnement
des communautés notamment fabre je veux
faire d'exercice pas que ça à faire
l'exercice stéphane minson vous êtes
emmanuel
kron vous gardez de voir philippe ou pas
qui je sens mâcon voilà alors si je suis
si je suis à l'elysée je prendrai déjà
quelques vacances je pense un peu
difficile
la première chose et puis et puis alors
ce que je gardais que lorsqu'il n'y
coupe pas j'avoue que je suis bien
content de paillettes pour ne pas voir
c'est vraiment choisir entre entre deux
entre deux mauvaises solutions et dans
celle ip populaire aujourd'hui
enfin c'est relatif il est quand même
assez populaire aujourd'hui donc si on
s'en débarrasse
en fait s'ils se débarrasse de fillon de
films comment s'appelle t les bords
phillips et ça il faut savoir par qui le
remplacer je pense c'est ça la vraie
question parce que se débarrasser d'un
premier ministre populaire il a intérêt
à la remplacer par quelqu'un qui s'il
n'est pas populaire aujourd'hui ou pas
très connus quoi que ce soit il ya un
sérieux comme on dirait un sérieux
moteur sous le capot on parle beaucoup
de la ministre de la défense florence
parly ce qui permettait à stéphane
mention de dire tout à l'heure
auront-elles chantal guérin deuxième
gouvernement irait gouvernement parly 2
roth hostel macron siv est un choix
lagon dernier c'est à dire que l'on
prend quelqu'un qui n'est pas très
connue qu'est ministre de la défense
nous placerait qu'il connaît bien le
fonctionnement de l'étape et qui connaît
bien que j'ai bien le droit de l'état
grosse macro vous vous gardez et doivent
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
que il a tout résumé
quelqu'un qui est populaire s qui alors
tout dépend des ambitions de des
ambitions d'edouard philippe dans le
fond et est en politique on sait que
l'amitié entre guillemets la loyauté
c'est pas forcément la vertu la plus
courante
donc je je
je sais pas moi je pense qu' il ferait
mieux de le garder parce que souvent en
premier ministre sortant ce même si ça
lui venait à l'esprit de se présenter en
général ils passent pas encore une fois
aujourd'hui il est has il est à ce
niveau entre guillemets dans les
sondages en corse a encore une fois ça
reste des sondages il à ce niveau là
mais en deux ans je peux vous dire que
ça peut ça peut ça peut aller très vite
je suis en salle mais moi je dois bien
évidemment je garde edouard philippe
mais je le garde pour deux raisons non
seulement parce qu'il est populaire mais
surtout parce que je trouve qu'il fait
très bien le job
donc voilà c'est à dire ne faut pas
toujours sur la fiche d'une popularité
une impopularité se trouve qu'il fait
remarquer combien le travail
il est pas dans la fanfaronnade il est
donc sérieux et il s'est débrouillé pour
le mans surtout pour gérer cette crise
du sanitaire sanitaires beaucoup mieux
que quiconque n'aurait pu le faire donc
bien évidemment je le garde
enfin je suis macro moi je garde
brigitte jeu je crois moi je veux dire
mon nom sur timo après tous désistés
je pense qu'il faut il faut qu'il parte
parce que si si si emmanuel mac on veut
être réélu il ne peut pas le faire sans
prendre de risque ne peut pas l'être
sans prendre de risque on n'est pas
réélu en faisant la même chose pendant
50 me semble-t-il mais enfin on verra
bien on n'a pas trop le temps
malheureusement est ce qui nous reste
que deux minutes de parler de la
convention citoyenne mais rost je
voulais avoir votre avis puisque on dit
qu'il va y avoir une réforme du conseil
économique social et environnemental
dont vous faites partie pour accueillir
justement c'est convention citoyenne
vous pouvez nous étions en une minute là
dessus ou globalement ça de ce qu'ils
appellent la chambre du futur c'est ce
qu'ils veulent faire c'est arrivé à
créer une institution justement où il y
aurait de temps en temps des citoyens
tirés au sort qui pourrait
éventuellement participer à ce genre
d'exercice bon alors sur la convention
citoyenne en tant que tel moi je suis un
peu dubitatif
ce rapport à ce qu'ils on est sortis ils
ont été très très dirigé par des
spécialistes qui ont plus ou moins
imposée lors leurs idées et l'histoire
des 110 km heure je pense qu'il faut
arrêter les conneries un moment donné
quand est ce que justement je suis
d'accord et crossed non chlorée avec
vous
malgré moi justement est-ce que ce que
tout ce qui ressort de cette convention
citoyenne
ça ne veut pas dire que ce serait le
moment de relancer la démocratie
représentative
bien sûr mais c'est la fin c'est la fin
de la démocratie justement de dire si
cette courte on citoyenneté c'est
l'oubli de l'expertisé l'oubli de
l'expérience c'est l'oubli de la
connaissance est d'ailleurs ces données
le pousser monsieur la parole les
experts qui reproduit les parties
essaient alors on va me servir de mes
praticité du plus stupides qu'ils
sortent un chapeau ça amuse les jambes
j'espère qu'on ne fera rien de tout ça
et ça sera rassurant parce que
franchement quand on voit les
propositions mais c'est à désespérer du
genre humain
merci merci beaucoup vincent couronne
merci beaucoup
ils ont charles lajoie ni merci beaucoup
rust et merci beaucoup stéphane manceau
est très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
paf vous voyez qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de sujets qu'on n'a pas pu aborder donc
le débat est toujours ouvert
[Musique]